alright hello everybody how are you it's
it's nice to be back in Portland
you know I'm traveling every time to us
for a conference and I think this is the
best city I've been so far I'm sorry if
anybody's from California actually I
started recognizing some of the streets
the weather kind of surprised me this
year but I think so right so this is the
SOG you've been waiting for this is the
the COI 101 the ultimate CLI talk that
you've been waiting for about the past
the present in the future including a
lot of undocumented stuff actually
that's everything pretty much so I want
you to come back from chain react to
your colleagues and tell them you know I
now mastered the react native tooling
hell yeah so let's get started we'll see
how it goes
so a couple of words about me I'm a core
contributor to react native I'm on a rag
native team I'm helping them with their
releases and I'm also working on the CLI
I'm also co-founder in Syria or coal
stack this is the company we found it
the does really react native we hope
companies around the world she reacts
react products and we also help you in
the open source community via the
contributions that we make and as they
said I'm also a petrol head I got a car
and I'm racing and something I'm really
proud of I just got my degree after
seven years so that's that's really
amazing
yeah amazing I use this applause to
adjust that all right so let me start
with a story that happens to me a while
back ago I have analyzed a lot that's me
on the picture by the way it's pretty
cool I traveled to many conferences
especially where Native developers are
hanging out
I do like converting them to JavaScript
which for some reason they don't like
you know usually nobody cares they just
move on but on the last conference in
track somebody did show up and I asked
him like how does it feel to develop
react native for you coming from the iOS
background and what he told me was that
I just don't think it's stable enough
and I'm like oh no again this kind of
discussion is happening over and over
I know react native is not one point X
yet who cares so I asked him to
elaborate or that a bit more and what he
told me is that he had few issues
including you know that the linking of a
dependency the building command didn't
work for him reliably and being an iOS
developer he also had no idea what that
really was
and obviously as soon as they launched
they got a red screen with some
stacktrace
they tried to debug it it took them a
while and in the meantime when a new
react native version got released they
wanted to upgrade and they spent quite
time doing that and then they realized
they also need to upgrade some of their
other dependencies so eventually they
just didn't releasing the offices and
they didn't hop on the latest cycle and
please raise your hand if this sounds
like you're getting started experience
see I can say that this sounds pretty
much like my getting started experience
I started when the react native was 0.5
or 6 and that was quite experienced and
as a result you know I think we've
learned how to deal with these things
over time by either another writing code
that we knew was expected to break or by
not using the libraries that we knew
were not going to work we subconsciously
started making decisions that we've
learned were guaranteed to get us there
but nobody said that this that way was
the most efficient one so let's now take
a look at the CLI it's as much of useful
commands and functionalities it's it's
beautiful
right I mean when I'm showing this to my
girlfriend she's like I have no idea why
you like this but for us engineers I
feel like that the tooling is kind of
something that makes us really happy but
the CLI has a problem it's a kitchen
sink of different features and they are
all 80% done and now I completely made
up this number but here is the thing it
requires some effort to get to that
premium level of polish that provides
comprehensive and reliable experience
for react native just look at the output
on screen it actually provides a lot of
useful information it's just that the
first time you see if you are like
what's going on and if only you know
there was some documentation to guide us
through this process and here is the
here is the thing we and I'm speaking
for me and my friends from the react
native community are biased you know
we've been into many issues with react
native over time and we've learned how
to mitigate them for example I know that
many of my friends are not using create
native link but they are linked in
libraries manually however react native
link is still the recommended way of
doing that so it's a bit unfair and at
the other side it also makes the command
itself untrustworthy because it doesn't
work reliably for everybody to use it
and also it brings me to my next point
which is you know people are whispering
like like you know there is this kid on
the block that's been you know hitting
with the marketing just riding to the
shortcomings of react native like hey we
got great docs we got great uikit like
everything is so great about us so you
start thinking that if the if the tools
they have are great and the UI kid they
have is great then the framework itself
must be fast performing and ready to use
for me right now at this point after a
spreading this apocalyptic state of you
know the tooling and even showing the
forbidden frameworks here let me make
one thing extremely clear we are all
good this is already happening what I'll
and actually that's what I'll be talking
about today in my talk
so a few months ago we have move out the
CLI to the new home under under their
link or effort and while doing that we
have quickly learned that there is a
bunch of issues that need to be fixed as
soon as possible
from really trivial mistakes such as
mixed up license headers throughout the
code from our sea view ones such as you
know the insanely long starts up time or
maybe this security header from rehab
which I've just learned about like a few
months ago so me t mikey and SMS ik my
friends of call stack and react native
community members felt like it was our
responsibility to quickly step up and
make the CLI usable and great again and
in fact we have already tried that in
the past with our own - called hall
which was an alternative to metro for
bundling react native apps of web pack
so we were prepared to face that we knew
what as the mean to actually start
working on the CLI we've run through
this so today I want to highlight some
of the areas that we have focused while
working on the v2 of the CLI in no
particular order I believe you know
these are the key traits that define the
command line tool and guarantee the
ultimate developer experience and see
I'm using ultimate all over that's
probably because of B and W if you know
they have the ultimate driving
experience so I'm kind of virtual head
inside out alright so if you are like me
you know if you first look at the
appearance of the tool you kind of start
judging the quality of it you know you
see and I still nice login you think
this is right I want to use it
unfortunately the CLI didn't do well in
that regard in the past you would get a
whole different experience depending on
the command you were interacting with
and the developer who actually made it
so there would be some commands having a
really nice output that a lot of
information and some commands having
literally nothing at all for example the
C of bundle identifier or one of the
most people are issues here you know has
been the result of a poor error handling
experience nothing more than that so the
fix was really easy and involved just
kind of returning early from a function
so as the error happened otherwise we
were trying to parse an iOS project that
wasn't compiled and so the error was
happening swallowing the real reason now
I know that these are messages don't
look nice and the error is not really
like the color is really hard to see but
this was in the middle of our work on
this feature we did it like a while back
ago so it was impossible for me to do
this screenshot one more time however
you know it kind of proves the point you
can see the error message is much better
maybe you can read it maybe not but at
least you get the real error message
instead of the CF bundle identifier so
while working on it we have also
enrolled our own logger you know we use
it across the CLI to generate the same
output regardless of the command so it
looks like a unified end product and
it's a part of the public interface of
the CLI so if you are ever going to work
on the CLI or commands feel free to use
that to kind of jump straight on to the
look and feel that we hire and we are
building for the CLI we have also
reworked the error handling with better
error messages and stack traces and we
have also added verbose mode and I think
this is huge if this creature doesn't
make you convinced don't worry I got a
bunch of other videos to kind of show
how it works in production but I think
it's really nice because now I look at
the CLI and I'm like ok I got an error I
know how to fix it always I know where
to look for it another thing is the
documentation like it's crucial you know
your tool could be the best in the world
could have a lot of great features but
there is little value that your users
will have if they are not documented at
all and this has been the case with the
CLI for a really long time many of the
features like the ones on screen were
not documented at all
they were only known to a very small
number of developers that had enough
time to dig through the code and learn
about them the hard way like mono repo
support or disabling linking when I was
browsing the Internet I was finding a
lot of questions like that and I was
repeating the same answer all over but
we never had a proper place to describe
these in a sort of guide section and
there were also a few tutorials
available online and now I'm really
happy that the community is stepping up
and and kind of making these materials
for us
however I don't think they should be do
you recommend it source for learning
about the fundamental features of the
CLI and react native there should be a
place for that so we decided to take
documentation seriously having a well
documented set of features and ideas can
be really useful to better understand
the CLI and be able to use it
efficiently and it's also kind of handy
for contributing so it's a nice side
effect that we made it and now we can
ask you for your help and so you now at
least know how to even form the project
because that wasn't really obvious in
the past so that's why the CLI has a new
documentation for every finger like
literally everything most importantly we
have described the notion of a platform
plugin project and i dependency things
that we used to confused even me a while
back ago and I'd like to use this slide
as an opportunity to say thanks to Tim
Mikey my friend who was working with me
if you have ever worked with him in the
open-source or if you ever get to work
with him in the open-source he you know
he is passionate about two things unit
tests and documentation so that's what
we got right in the CLI like he just
couldn't accept APR without these so
platform is a package that ships with
code that allows you to extend react
native of a platform so think react
native Windows has windows react native
has Android and iOS built-in we'll cover
that in details a bit in a second plug
in for example on the other hand this is
a pact that extends CLI with additional
functionality if you have been using
gree and if you have been using the
great tools that infinite red is making
they are extending the CLI will prove
some with some some great commands and
that's been always possible but now it's
it's properly documented and no longer
you know considered private API back in
the day you had to reach out to somebody
like me and I would have to tell you
here's how we can do it dependency on
the other hand is a package that
contains react native code to be linked
so it's not a NPM dependency it's more
like a dependency that has you know
native iOS or a native Android code that
you might be linking in the future in
project that's nothing but your react
native project so it contains
information about all the platforms all
the dependencies basically the whole
environment that you're working with and
we'll also talk about that in a second
so just listing these down to get us on
the same page before we can't
so the performance now it depends pretty
much on the way you are interacting with
the CLI like for example if you are
running run iOS or start command the the
kind of the core of the command will
take like 99% of the execution time so
any improvements that we do to the CLI
itself will you will not even notice
it's gonna be fast anyway I mean it's
gonna be slow anyway however one of the
biggest performance bottlenecks was the
performance startup which was caused by
two things the use of Babel register and
now the reason for that is that the
react native CLI being part of react
native repo was kind of following the
same architecture in the same setup and
as you know react native itself is not
transpiled and dependencies we we create
are not transpiled as well everything
happens during runtime so we were using
Babel register to do that during runtime
as well on the on the on the client side
and we were also processing all node
modules dependencies in order to know
what native dependencies you have and
what we should link so if you had react
native webview and other modules in your
package Jason we will have to go through
the whole node modules folder and find
them so extracting the CLI out of the
react native lifted a lot of constraints
and let us roll a whole new architecture
to make that even better so we ended up
changing the the published step and
transpiling the code ahead of time and
that makes the code load almost
instantly for you without making making
the CLI experience much more enjoyable
and as a result we have observed a
dramatic performance improvement during
a startup like two seconds faster and
now then we also shaved the the startup
time by an additional half a second so
from free like now the startup time
takes 0.2 seconds so that's like instant
so it was very easy to set up you know
and I'd like to encourage you to do the
same for your libraries as well right
now we need to transpile them during the
runtime but I'd really love to get us
closer to the reality Co system and just
kind of encourage us to do that before
we publish to the Mojo so as you can see
the performance improvements are right
there for us it was more than 2 seconds
so we can now multiply that by the
amount of time you open the CLI
and I think it's gonna be like one day
per year depending on the amount of
projects you have another thing is the
configuration and that's my favorite
part because I messed it up so it's been
implementing the react native in a
really complicated way so don't worry if
the following slides make no sense to
you there are three ways to alter the
CLI behavior like how many of you have
heard of the iron CLI config please
raise your hand
all right the Metro config I see the
Facebook people raising their hands
that's good and the RMP I'm in
package.json okay that's that's also
quite quite impressive anyway see like
that was probably 10% of the audience so
I think that kind of brings me to the
brings us to the point that these things
are not documented properly and are kind
of mysterious
so whoever uses them is like wow you
have some hacks in your codebase what
are you doing so I see somebody making
photo please don't this is gum I will
show you the alternative in a second so
first there was desirous you like config
I guess so I have three examples of each
file and I'm gonna show you how we can
use types because it's cool so this is
how you can integrate typescript with
the RNC like config and now here's the
confusing part when I started working
with react native my first thought was
RS CLI is for configuring to react
native CLI it's not it's for Metro but
back in a day when a match was started
it was part of react native Metro was
the first command you can think of mesh
was the first command of the react
native CLI so back in the day when the
team made the metro and the config it
was the same thing
so it's just the naming confusion then
after they made Metro a standalone
project they created the wrong
configuration mechanism on top of cosmic
config called Metro config Jia's that
has a slightly different shape in this
case it's an object and as you can see
it has less conflicts and then on the
before screen in the previous screen and
then you can still set the mysterious RM
p.m. key in a package.json
to configure different properties about
your project and native dependencies
that you're working with and you know
this was meant to be temporary and I
think our NPM is not anything for like
three years already
and still we can and we need to
configure it sometimes so I think that's
really confusing for you so the point is
things are complex and and that's why we
have decided to just drop it all and
start from scratch with an entirely new
format that would be simple in the first
place
and the new configuration is also based
on custom config and uses namespaces to
combine all the different purposes that
different files had to satisfy for
example if you are developing a native
module or any native component you are
going to be most interested in changing
settings under the dependency key
because what you are building is a
dependency right these properties are
then used to resolve the final
configuration now this is the final
configuration of the project and you can
see it today by running react native
config in your in your in your project
it's inferred based on many things so
you probably agree with me and you are
thinking that this is rather complex and
kind of like has a lot of different
settings so the idea is I believe that
in react native projects the files are
convention like I can tell a lot about
your project just by the files and I'm
not talking about the naming patterns in
the structure and more about you know
like what kind of different files you
have you have native iOS or native
Android files so we are trying to infer
as much as we can to lift the
requirement from you to set all things
up so we are kind of trying to be more
like expert in that sense that you don't
have to mess around with native code too
much and so if we make a mistake like if
we infer something wrong we can change
that pretty easily for example let's say
you want to disable link in react native
webview on iOS like you just don't want
it so all you have to do is just set is
property to know nothing more and this
will be deep merged with the previous
County that I showed you so as a result
you will get an iOS set to know in the
final config like running reg native
link now we'll skip webview from being
linked on iOS entirely just like here in
fact the CLI will think that it's
working with the Android only library
and apart from that we also validate
your configuration to eliminate mistakes
so if you make a typo like I did with
platforms you will get an information
early on that it sounds
not working and you will be able to go
over and fix the mistake and then start
it all over so we are using joy to
validate the schema we have the schema
defined with so of types and it makes it
really easy to work with and now one
great thing before I go to this slide
like from the maintenance perspective is
that many of the issues in the react
native freepo where like start command
is broken react native link is not
working properly and we were asking for
reproduction and it was hard to give it
now all you have to do is just generate
the configure output just paste it in
the issue and I'll know right away
what's going wrong and if not I can just
take this JSON put it as a fixture to my
tests and see right away what's going on
so last thing is that as I said any
performance sections we were eagerly
parsing the whole node modules and
trying to get the whole dependence that
you have we have changed that so now
it's lazy so what we gonna do is we're
gonna evaluate node modules as soon as
you start asking for dependencies so if
you're running start command log iOS or
whatever we are not gonna do this
evaluation at all because you're not
gonna be accessing that so the only
place where we will be accessing this is
inside link I think and a few other
commands so let's talk about link so how
many of you have used it at least once
in their lives all right cool so judging
by the amount of hands it's probably one
of the most popular commands I'm pretty
sure if we did any kind of tests and
evaluated the popularity the disease
will be one of the most popular commands
however the point is when I first
implemented this command with my friend
Alexa graph we considered it an MVP like
we thought it's better to have something
than nothing and we wanted to provide
better support in the future so for
example we parse iOS files using gain
unmaintained and unstable parser and the
idea was we will write our own in a
future but we never got around that and
I know what you're thinking right now
but I think it's actually good that we
haven't done that over time turns out
that the assumptions we had were based
on wrong principle
rather than scripting the platform and
trying to write parsers we should have
embraced the platform and use the EPI
stubbly interface that it had from the
very beginning and that's what the new
link is all about it drops the bad parts
about the link and takes the ones that
were actually good so first it embraces
the platform it uses what community has
been already defaulting to when handling
native dependencies talk apples and
Gradle second it's fully automatic as
ROM told you hooking into the platform
natively gives us the ability to resolve
project dependencies right away when the
compilation happens so we no longer have
to run the parser yourself ahead of time
and the last is platform agnostic by
default so adding support for third
party platform like Windows will be
super easy and now the whole big idea
behind link is that next year I'm not
gonna be here talking about link we
wanted to be automatic and happen behind
the scenes so we want this experience to
be seamless on a high level both
platforms require you to include a
special line in your in their respective
configuration files so for example in
iOS you need to add a Ruby function to
your pod file and on Android you have to
modify some Gradle files on a low level
they both run react native config behind
the scenes to get the information what
to link and how to link it in a
cross-platform way all you know if react
native is about cross-platform
development I think the CLI should also
embrace that paradigm so I actually
would like to thank X buffer and the
whole team especially sebastian camilla
thomas abbot and brent for pioneering
this approach I'm not an expert when it
comes to native development so seeing
that such things were possible with
their URI modules actually open up my
eyes and helped us kind of innovate in
that aspect as well and you know we are
working really closely with expert
together and this is something that I
really wanted to explicitly say like
many times I open the react native
community group on Facebook there's a
lot of people many people asking you
know like should I use expert or not and
and there are like comments like don't
use Expo it's it's really bad like why
would you use Expo and different things
like I really don't like it and I wanted
to spread this this notion that we are
not actually like fighting against each
other we are
working all together and we are working
closely with Expo team to not reinvent
the wheel all over and that's why we are
taking inspirations from each other and
actually working towards making the CLI
our experience for both Expo and react
native developers because you can eject
and soon Expo will be even easier to use
for react native developers so we want
to make the experience the same so thank
you for that another thing is the new
architecture and you know we kind of
really CL I used to be really tightly
coupled with the internals and so now
has a separate repo so we were able to
change the infrastructure and now I'm
bringing this on this store because I
think it influenced a lot of great
things that we came up with later so we
have structured it in the mono repo like
I laughed on the repos the first time I
learned that when the repos are world
you know cool big companies are using I
also wanted to use them and so when I
heard about Lync or my first well my
first thought was like can I make it am
on the repo and everybody was like yeah
yeah you can do it so I did it and and
then right away I started splitting the
packages into smaller ones I was like
super extremely happy that I'm making it
and and you know we made each of these
packages to be responsible for a single
thing so so such architecture you know
the good thing is that it promotes
public interface over private call sites
and hard-coded usages for example the
Android and iOS platforms are now in
separate packages and are both a
platform and a plugin at the same time
so they contain commands such as run iOS
and log iOS and field files needed for a
link so these are no longer hard-coded
in the CLI itself CLI doesn't know about
that at all and react native then pulls
these packages from NPM
Android and registers them I'm gonna
show you the use in a second and what's
more it's also easier to contribute in
my team for example we can gradually
start migrating packages to typescript
just like we migrated tools so this kind
of separation of concerns and an
architecture makes such transitions
really smooth so now let's talk about
platform support how many of you have
used any platform rather than Android
and iOS please raise your hand okay I
think okay cool so not many so
planning to change that you know react
native has been always by but learning
once and writing everywhere however in
reality the support for additional
platforms has never been easy like this
is something we are working on right now
the framework started as an iOS and then
Android was added in a single commit
with others to follow
so both platforms were hard-coded and
not following a like a common public
interface because there wasn't a need
for for such thing so this made
integration really complicated and
require a lot of hacks so when
extracting the CLI we decided to make
all the new features platform century by
default so today platforms are
first-class citizens in the CLI as well
you know supported throughout the code
and I'm hoping that this will lead to
even smoother integration of other
platforms and spread react native on
entirely new targets so first what we
did is we have completely extracted the
Android and iOS specific code two
separate packages with a public API and
some files and then we have made react
native to behave like an out of tree
platform itself that is it melded colors
support for Android and iOS just like
react native Windows so in fact there is
no longer a concept of a out of tree
platform or external platform or
anything like that all the packages now
declare platforms using the same
interface so technically speaking in the
future you might be using just iOS if
there is react native iOS package for
example so you could just sweep out
Android pieces from here and you would
be getting iOS only development in case
you need it and that's about not one the
upgrading so I left the best mount for
the end so how many of you upgrade apps
manually right would you use the tooling
if it was working reliably see there you
go so I guess you know I I kind of knew
the answer gonna be hell yeah because
why not right so like historically
speaking we had a lot of ways of doing
that including the upgrade and get
upgrade they were not really like well
may teen and they were serving up like
they were not acting as you would expect
for example like the get upgrade itself
were
comparing the react native init project
with your project files generating the
git diff and then applying that diff
onto your files and so it sounds great
by definition but there were a lot of
conflicts over time and it never kind of
lets you upgrade more complex devs so
that's why we have decided so I
integrate the rnd purge by default which
is another get upgrade mechanism that is
also part of the react Native community
now and what it does is it generates
dips between two blank react native
projects and then this DF is applied on
to your projects so the difference is
that it's more reliable and also it's
cloud based so it allows you an ass to
check the diffs ahead of time so here is
a screen shot of me trying to upgrade my
app the latest react native to try out
Hermes and as you can see I got some
information and the diff has been
applied and I see exactly what files
were changed all some having changes to
pod file because I upgraded to 0.60 that
has the outer linking support now the
big thing is if this doesn't work which
is possible you get this great online
upgrade guide tool that will basically
let you know what are the differences
and you will be able to check the D fure
self and apply the changes manually and
sure this is not enough for very very
serious breaking changes but as react
native is maturing and we are having
less of them this should be enough and
even more efficient as we go so please
give it a try if you had tried upgrading
with the CLI before and you didn't like
it we'd love to get your feedback and
improve that even further so the last
thing I'm going to mention today but
equally important is the getting started
experience and this one's amazing I mean
historically speaking this been really
rough for react native developers for us
so the process involved you know
installing a global command and then
running react native in it on top of it
and from the maintenance perspective
it's been extremely hard to set up and
as a result they come on itself like the
Polish you'd expect from the first
command you ever run with react native
because nobody wanted to work on it
because it was just so hard to set it up
so the important information was
swallowed in a sea of output that was
being printed by
the subprocesses so for example the CLI
was installing the NPM dependencies that
would take up the whole screen and
possibly had something very important or
something that you might be interested
in so we have changed the entire engine
to be more interactive and beautiful to
look at yeah
so the output of subprocesses is no
longer printed on screen instead you get
nice loader and you can follow along
each of the steps as you can see we have
also added the automatic apples
installation for you because that's now
required starting from 0-60 so it looks
professional impaired with how react
native great is itself and it's actually
one of like my goals and goals of my
team that we want the CLI to be the best
in the market so we are tired of people
asking if react native is dead we now
want to react native CLI to be like the
the top player in the game that
everybody is looking like I want to be
like them and it's also not gonna use
the global package so no more upgrading
issues no more issues with running react
native unit we are encouraging to use
MPX so feel free to give it a try so
let's talk about the future now our team
at coalesce tag you know is and will
keep working on the project and
governing the development we are
particularly excited about tools for
some reason we just like them so we'd
like to make react native experience
even better for you but most importantly
we want you to be productive feeling
right at home and having all the tools
you need and to do so we need your help
now that the CLI has been moved out to a
react Native community it's never been
easier to contribute to give us feedback
and help us working so join us in the
open source and let's make react native
tooling great thank you very much
[Applause]
get up give it up oh wait okay wait
there's nothing else take yes I do wait
as my must have one more thing that I'm
always making but yeah thanks for the
applause and I got yourself a bonus for
that so we run a react native you
conference in Europe in September it
says the the conference happens in
Poland and so I got a discount code for
you if you'd like to go there's gonna be
a lot of people from chain react
traveling there as well so feel free to
make a photo or just reach out to me and
I will give you another discount as well
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]